when you meet Marcus Holloway in the
story he's a young hacker who is for the
first time having a sort of sense of
community and family with other hackers
Marcus is a programmer self-taught his
passionate he's a fighter his
personality is a lot of fun I think he's
just been cool
Marcus was somebody that was raised in
Oakland at the beginning of the game he
hacks into a system and you see he's got
a profile right all these labels are
pushed upon him because of where he's
from his family's history the system has
said this is who he is and he's fighting
against it Marcus is fighting against
injustice at his very essence at the
core of everything and he just wants
everything to be fair it's about our
loss of privacy it's about our loss of
control over our online
it's even worse than you thought it was
and because of this he knows he needs
more power behind him and a way to do
that is to find a group of like-minded
people with the same skill sets to work
together to fight against the system
that sex is a worldwide organization but
for us we're dealing specifically with
the cell that's in San Francisco because
dead sex is many voices Marcus comes
along because he's looking for the right
group and what's wonderful about dead
second San Francisco is the diversity oh
by far Marcus's closest friend in the
game is the wrench wrench is the
resident engineer and also problem
solver he's the demolition man you know
if you need anything blown up or like
he's gonna go out and create some
anarchy he just likes getting into
trouble he wants to get into a good
fight my character cetera she's the
rebel she's playful but she's also very
serious she just purpose guitar she
likes to do graffiti and all types of
artwork she's the one responsible for
creating all the visuals that debt sex
gonna use so it really becomes more
memorable she's looking to change things
through her art through her message she
wants to engage people mentally and then
we also have Joshua i think is very much
our human connection josh is in the
group not very outspoken but when he
does he has something important to say
and often inappropriately so he's the
brain he's the coder anything tech-heavy
he's gonna do it and figure it out this
guy can hack to her anything he bypassed
any firewall
they're not trying to take down society
they're good people who are trying to do
something right and trying to discover
something and just curious we see the
evolution of the group itself throughout
the game and it's their sort of
connection and journey together that
drives the rest of the game forward I
think anybody can relate to the joy that
Marcus brings to the missions and also
the passion that he brings to it he
still has fun he represents the fun
aspects of the hacker culture and he
does parkour and he's got drones he's
driving to this phone I wish I could do
that people were really gonna relate to
the fire underneath the engine when
Marcus get started and he's trying to
finish something click here to join dead
set and receive exclusive in-game
rewards and more subscribe to our
YouTube channel and be the first to see
new trailers and behind-the-scenes
action